und jetzt schauen wir aber erstmal auf
den riesen Schock für 162 Flugzeug
Passagiere aus Südkorea die Landung
ihres Flugzeugs auf den Philippinen die
gegen nämlich mächtig schief und landete
tatsächlich abseits der Landebahn
am Morgen nach der missglückten Landung
wird das ganze Ausmaß des Schadens klar
der vordere Unterboden des Flugzeugs ist
komplett zerstört die Nase stark
beschädigt am späten Sonntagabend möchte
dieser Airbus A330 der Korean Airlines
auf der philippinischen Insel mactan
landen doch das schlechte Wetter macht
den Piloten Probleme sie brechen zwei
Landeversuche wieder ab ehe sie beim
dritten Versuch über die Landebahn
hinausschießen das Flugzeug bleibt mit
der Nase im Gras stecken alle 162
Passagiere und die elf
Besatzungsmitglieder kommen jedoch mit
dem Schrecken davon verletzt wird bei
der harten Landung niemand die Insassen
können sich über die Not rutschen aus
dem Flugzeug retten auch die örtlichen
rettungskräfte sind schnell vor Ort und
betreuen die Insassen der Flughafen ist
auf unbestimmte Zeit geschlossen alle
Flüge mit dem Ziel mactan werden
umgeleitet
da denkt man sich auch da will ich nicht
drin gesessen haben Gott sei Dank
[Musik]